[Music]
foreign
have you ever wondered why the dragons
of House of the dragon and Game of
Thrones differ in size even if they were
of the same age or why some have an
accelerated growth rate While others
remain stagnant in size or grow at a
slow pace well let's discuss the seven
different factors that influence a
dragon's growth rate number one age this
is the first factor and the most
important as dragons are said to grow
throughout their lives while there are
six other criteria that limits or spurts
a dragon's growth rate age is the most
important the older a dragon is the
bigger the dragon will be take Valerian
for instance he was the biggest known
dragon in the universe of A Song of Ice
and Fire he was around 200 years old by
the time he died and at the same time he
was the biggest Vega who was the second
biggest is also the second oldest dying
in battle at the age of 181 years of age
while Verma Thor the third largest was
also a around 100 years old at his time
of demise
number two captivity this is another
factor that was stated explicitly in
Game of Thrones that dragons in
captivity don't get room enough to grow
they are like sharks in a way if a shark
is put in an enclosed space it won't
grow to the same size as it would have
if it was set free in the Open Seas the
dragon pit in a way was the Doom of the
targaryen's Dragons the dragons that
were housed there were of a small size
than the ones of Dragonstone dream fire
was often locked up in a dragon pit and
was smaller than worm Thor and
Silverwing even though she was older or
around the same age even rhaegar and
viserion became visibly smaller than
drogon because they were in The Dungeons
of marine
number three breed this is the next big
thing that really defines how big a
dragon will be as stated by the creators
of House of the Dragon there were three
different breeds of dragons the biggest
were the dinosaur type breeds like vegar
and worm Thor while the wolf type breeds
were of middle status like garaxis even
though he was deformed and melees who
was old but yet had a body size that was
only a bit bigger than drogon the
smallest were the horse type breeds like
Cyrax and Sunfire they are more Nimble
in the air but size wise they were
nowhere close to the other breeds Cyrax
should have grown exponentially during
the time jumps but stayed almost the
same if not a tiny bit bigger
number four blood magic it is stated
that dragons are believed to be
intrinsically tied to Magic in the world
since the death of The Last Dragon
Summers grew shorter and Winter's colder
while magical spells became less
powerful when Danny's dragons were born
magic return and this was kind of a
feedback loop as the Resurgence of magic
initiated in the blood and fire ritual
also probably accelerated the growth
rate of the Three Dragons Dem growing to
a full size in seven years as compared
to a young juvenile sized air acts of
six years old as undeniably a fact that
blood magic was the cause of their large
sizes at a young age drogon at 8 years
old was nearly as big as melees who was
more than 80 years old
number five ambient magic we know that
Valerian was the only Targaryen Dragon
alive at the time of the conquest who
was born before the Doom of valyria and
his birth in a more magical place and
time may have contributed to his huge
size it was evident that valerians were
powerful magic users and their specialty
in Fire magic was unmatched so they also
probably use it to manipulate Dragon
sights and growth rate at the height of
the Valyrian Freehold their Peninsula
aided by the 14 fires created an ambient
environment of Fire magic like a
surround sound system therefore the
pre-doom era Valeria would have produced
larger dragons than Westeros where there
was no magic at all
number six individuality this is also a
good Factor there is also the case of
individual dragons having their specific
genes to be bigger or smaller the prime
example is drogon he is said to be the
living Reincarnation of valerian the
black dread and so he possessed the
innate criteria within him to be big and
grow faster than his other siblings
when they hatch out from their eggs it
was clearly stated that drogon was
already slightly bigger than the other
two who were rhaegar and viserion even
after accounting to the fact that all
three Dragons Were hatched at the same
time with the same Fire and Blood Magic
Ritual
and number seven the generation factor
of all the Targaryen dragons that we
know Valerian lived to be around 200
years of age and was the largest by the
time of the dance of the Dragons vegar
was approaching the size of the black
dread even though she was born in
Dragonstone 52 years before the conquest
but a strange thing is that these
dragons that were born in Westeros
always became smaller in size every
successive generation the second
generation dragons like Verma Thor dream
fire and Silverwing were way smaller
than vegar the third generation which
were caraxis and melees were of middle
size the first generation dragons like
Cyrax were even smaller this went on and
on to the loss of the Targaryen dragons
grew to be the size of a small dog
and that's where we will end with the
seven factors of dragon growth
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
next time take care fam